your mom plays professional basketball
in the WNBA yes no way so you definitely
don't come from
[Applause]
money that was a low blow I'm sorry but
it was also such a layup you know was
your mom good would you say she was the
D Jordan of the
[Laughter]
W that is pretty cool though did you get
to go to a lot of games growing up yeah
I did you sat Courtside absolutely was
it
lonely some of that was funny the D
Jordan thing was very funny and he
obviously set it up perfectly it became
personal with me the only thing I don't
like is when comedians laugh at their
own jokes a little bit is okay but
otherwise I find it offputting he was
really laughing at his own jokes but it
was pretty good he's obviously he's
talented